vous savez pourquoi vos pieds sentent le
fromage
vous pliez sans que le fromage arrêtez
un peu sur vos pieds il y a des peaux
mortes de la sueur et une espèce de
graisse qui s'appelle le sébum et tout
ça bah ça fait un petit festin pour les
bactéries donc les bactéries elles se
battent et quand elles ont bien mangé
quand elles ont fini elles rejettent
divers substances comme l'acide ISO
valérique qui donne cette odeur
caractéristique parmi ces bactéries il y
en a qui sont de la famille des brevis
bactérium et c'est vrai vie bactérium
elles sont aussi utilisées pour
l'affinage de certains fromages comme le
Maroilles le Munster ou la raclette
voilà maintenant vous savez que le
fromage sent le caca de bactéries et que
c'est les mêmes bactéries que celles que
vous avez sur les pieds il me reste plus
qu'à vous souhaiter un bon appétit